[Musique]
second soir faites revenir ce kirby
attend d'eux
faites mijoter trois bons quarts de
va vous attendre
et s'il n'est pas encore parti soyez en
sûr c'est qu'il est cuit sans votre avis
ils essaient freby
enfant se passer du beurre et de la
crème c'est impossible parce que
qu'est-ce qui a fait la renommée de la
cuisine française
c'est finalement toulon chris bear tous
nos crus de crem d'ailleurs voyez là ce
matin enfin un peu de cuisine qui passe
moi je la crème et sans crème c'est pas
possible de travailler d'envoyer on
travaille avec des crèmes de normandie
qui sont très très épaisse et c'est ça
finalement à green française est-ce que
c'est interchangeables les huiles lait
beurre lait de la crème dans les
cuiseurs la crème peut remplacer le
beurre parce que vous savez si on tourne
un peu finalement ça fait du beurre mais
remplacer le beurre et la crème
je pense qu'on a encore rien trouvé et
voyez un comme on dit a lyon tous nos
plats ils sont gourmands ils sont
gourmands de crem qui sont romands de
deux bords vous voyez saint yves de crem
ça dure pas longtemps chez nous on passe
une moyenne dans notre restaurant de 200
g de crème par client au map et le
cuisinier bleus attendant c
[Musique]